thank you thank you good night so far
damn a good night as far as taking home
this award but also good night cuz
you've got good company with you this
yeah my daughter mags with me tonight
you know I Gracie my oldest daughters at
our wedding this weekend my youngest
daughters in a high school play this
weekend and and it was picking Maggie up
from college and and she wanted to come
with me so it was great yeah it's really
trying to keep me from dancing that's
the biggest thing yeah
don't let her do that no don't let her
keep you too dad don't embarrass me I
kind of agree with her I'm not a dancer
you want a real workout kick there for a
while you still get hit try I try to
keep you know I did a friend of mine
invited me to SoulCycle okay I did my
first ulcer I do CrossFit I feel a lot
of work but I did soul psycho Beyonce
SoulCycle weird or not a real ride a
morning and it just about kicked my ass
what do you think but there's it's
pretty it's pretty inspiring and fun and
kind of gets you go along but it's
intense I mean for skinny legg guy I
mean I know biking stuff and I'm always
trying to get you know you if you got
skinny legs you're always trying to
figure out ways to build your legs
though that's one way that's one way to
do it it's also like for guys that sort
of emphasize the upper body workout I
mean so like he can't get away with that
no no no it was tough
you